An energetic man is striding around the launch canvas, laid on the floor,
a half bird cigarette filter, stuck to his lips.
He wears jeans and a white t-shirt. Despite the freezing cold in his studio,
a large space with neither heating or electricity, the man drips, fling,
splashes, dollops of painters. If in raptured,
Dom's taking cues from a melody,
which only he can hear the painting that is taking shape as an abstract pattern.
It looks both vaguely patterns and totally random.
Is this an expression of chaos?
The painter might reply no chaos down it that pains with Jackson, Paul,
like a polarizing artist, if there ever was one,
his paintings can mesmerize art lovers. They can also incite observers to shout.
My toddler could do it better in today's biographics we will decode his troubled
life and hermetic art, a cocktail which features youngian psychoanalysis,
fractals, and CIA involvement.
[Inaudible].
Well, Jackson was born on January the 28th, 1912 in Cody, Wyoming.
The town took its name from its founder count or William Cody,
better known as Buffalo bill Polix Beth place would contribute to his
mythologized status as a cowboy zone, which was indeed a myth,
but it was one never felt the need to correct.
His parents were Stella may Muchler and Leroy Paula,
or rather Laroy McCoy.
But young Leroy had lost both his parents in the span of a few months and had
been raised by his neighbors.
The Pollocks Jackson was the youngest of five boys.
All of whom stellar hoped would become artists of some kinds in her eyes.
They were all potential geniuses, which suggests the image of a loving mother,
proud of her children.
But the family atmosphere may not have been that rosy a later letter written by
one of the public boys,
do his brother discusses Jackson's emotional instability and psychological
problems in his eyes. These day back to his childhood,
to his relations with his family and our mother that's also of emotional
instability may have been tied to a constant sense of displacement.
When Jackson was 10 months old,
the family relocated near San Diego and eight months later to Phoenix,
Leroy was moving around the States,
looking for better job opportunities or buying and selling lands in 1917 when
Jackson was five Leroy drags the family back to California,
this time Chico all in all during the first 10 years of his life.
Jackson lived in six different houses across three different States and
1921, the oldest of the public boys,
Charles moved to Los Angeles to work at the Los Angeles times and to study at
the Otis art Institute from LA,
he would send back home copies of art and literary magazines,
which had a great influence on his younger brothers.
The magazines also included reproductions of contemporary European art,
especially of the Paris school and especially of public Casso.
This is our Jackson's lifelong obsession with a Spanish artist.
They have begun in 1923, the Pollocks moved back to Phoenix.
This was another key milestone in Jackson's formative years in Arizona,
he visited native American reservations and learns about that culture,
their traditions, and of course their art. And is that all years,
he admitted that his gestural or action painting technique owed a debt of
gratitude to native American peoples,
such as the Navaho in the Mojave that works included abstract designs painted on
a flat area, laying on the grounds. The artists used paint. Sure,
but also sand and other raw materials.
Jackson did not have much time to learn from these techniques.
This Leroy relocated again to California in 1924, three years later,
the young was a freshman at the Riverside high school near Los Angeles.
And it was not a nice experience.
He didn't fit in neither with the classes nor with his classmates.
His father wrote to the school and concerned about the boys difficulties with
social communication. Well, he did find a way to communicate,
but it wasn't very social Jackson engaged in violent behavior and was eventually
expelled for fighting in March of 1928.
Jackson moved to downtown LA and is enrolled in the manual arts high school
garnering to further expulsions and a reputation as a rebel with, well,
some cause this time it wasn't for fighting.
But for participating in student protests inspired by his father,
his socialist ideals Jackson took every opportunity to March and protest
traditional authority. It was a busy,
the school had him kicked out as he thoroughly enjoyed classes in drawing and
sculpture.
He was forming an identity of his future self as an artist and one letter to his
brothers, Jackson Roche, as to what I would like to be.
It is difficult to say an artist of some kind while he figured out what kind
exactly Jackson and his brother Sanford worked for a Roy employed as a
topographical surveyor from 1927 to 1930. During those years,
the teenage followed Lou Ryan, his crew in surveys of the grand Canyon,
enjoying the vast landscapes of the West.
Unfortunately he also enjoyed something else working with rugged older,
Matt exposed him to alcohol at a very young age.
It became a habit then a lifelong addiction in later life as a successful
artist, he was known for becoming aggressive after a few glasses and kicking off
arguments at parties,
which sometimes generated into brawls at the ends of the grand Canyon years.
Jackson wrote to big brother Charles,
that the so-called happy years of youth had been to him.
A bit of a downable hell
Joel's was definitely a big influence on Jackson and a trailblazer that led him
into the world of art. In 1936,
Charles had moved to New York to make it as a paint up.
When Jackson joins him in 1930,
the older brother introduced him to one of his teachers, notable artist,
Thomas Hart, Benton in 1930 Jackson,
moved in with Charles and also became a student of the Bensons.
This is the period in which public's formal training really took off when his
disparate influences coalesced and when his style became more distinctive Benson
introduced him to Italian masters of the Renaissance to Mexican muralists like
Siqueros and Riviera.
And so the movements that he champions American regionalism public's work in the
mid 1930s reflects Benson's influence take the painting.
Cotton pickers for the stall is still clearly figurative the subject massive
deals with social injustice in a rural setting,
both elements are typical of the regionalist style and both are elements which
forms an important stepping stone in Pollock's career.
Although he would eventually break away from recognizable figures and from
explicitly political themes in the late 1930s and early 1940s Jackson was
exposed to another source of profound inspiration in attempts to find his
alcoholism, anger issues, and bouts of depression.
Paula comes to when psychotherapy sessions first with Dr. Joseph Henderson from
1938 to 1941.
And then with Dr. Violet stabbed a Lazio in 1941 and 90, 42,
his therapists introduced Jackson.
So the methods of call Gustave young and especially the concept of youngian
unconscious. According to him,
the human psyche includes three main interacting systems, the ego,
the personal unconscious and the collective unconscious,
the ego represents the conscious mind. And as it comprises, the thoughts,
memories, and emotions,
we are aware of the personal unconscious contains forgotten information and
personal repressed memories.
The collective unconscious is instead shared by members of the human species and
is made up of late memories from my ancestral and evolutionary past.
When Paula found it difficult to communicate his feelings to Dr. Henderson,
he brought along some of his sketches.
That's out of 83 drawings dating from this period is known as the psychoanalytic
drawings. They capture a transitional periods in Pallex Korea.
He is leaving behind his early figurative work and shifting towards what would
become his signature style abstract expressionism.
The drawings display the clear influence of Young's theory as public uses
symbols, belonging to the collective unconscious symbols, like the snake.
According to young,
this is a stand-in for sex or for the baser lower parts of human nature.
In fact, snakes often appear at the bottom of Pollock's work at the top.
One may find suns, moons and eyes symbols of higher psychic States,
the sun disk and moon crescents, two of public's favorites.
The sun symbolizes the male unconscious elements of the psyche while the moon
represents femininity.
And the unconscious likes to combine the symbols into a launch or shape,
according to professor Michael layer of Pennsylvania university,
this may indicate and attempted reconciliating the artist's conscious and
unconscious States Pollock's work started to show another sign of the effects of
the unconscious in the early 1940s.
This is the period in which started to incorporate pain dripping on a horizontal
canvas, as a preferred technique.
The act of dripping paints by using brushes sticks or even Turkey based is had
been influenced by native American artists as we have seen,
but also by the Mexican painter Securus, according to Michael free,
there is a further collective force at work.
And that is the unconscious mind influenced about union studies.
may have given free reign to his unconscious.
The apparently random lines created by paint dripping of the embodiment of pure
energy generated by repressed memories. The piece of art,
which perfectly exemplifies youngian unconscious of play is guardians of the
secret. 1943, the canvas features a painting within a painting.
A rectangular shape filled with abstract markings is flanked by two figures,
stylized renditions of a man and a woman.
The central rectangle may be a representation of the unconscious with its
chaotic expression kept in check by the two human figures.
These figures may symbolize the animals and the animal young describes these as
the mirror images of aren't biological sex. For example,
men would have an animal that unconscious feminine side young wants to find the
animus and anima as guardians of the threshold.
A definition which public borrowed for the paintings title guardians was the
most striking piece in Pollock's first set of exhibition.
And it got him noticed.
[Inaudible].
In particular,
polar caught the eye of wealthy art collector and patron Peggy Guggenheim.
Peggy went to visit Jackson that's the flatty shed in New York with his
girlfriends Lee Krasner.
Lee was also a painter who would go on to have a long and influential career
after climbing four long flights of stairs.
The exhausted Peggy found nobody home just when she was about to leave the
building. She bumped into a drunk Jackson back from a friend's wedding party.
They in Jackson showed Peggy their respective works.
The patron was mildly interested in politics and totally dismissive of
crassness. There may have been some jealousy at work they're Guggenheim.
They have developed. And in fact, uation with pelicans,
always resented Lee's presence in his life.
Peggy walked away irritated by politics behavior,
but impressed by his looks and charisma.
Ultimately it was her advisor pens out Marcel to chomp who convinced her to give
Jackson a chance. And so it was that in July of 1943,
received a commission to create a mural for Peggy's new townhouse.
He was free to choose the subjects, but not the size.
The work needed to cover an entire wall,
81 feet long and almost 20 feet high chose to paint with oil on canvas
rather than directly on the wall, even. So the size of the frame was huge.
His studio was divided into two rooms, none of which was large enough.
Paula ended up tearing down the petition ball.
The deadline was November the sixth,
the days in which Guggenheim that offered to stage an exhibition of Publix art
Jackson immediately set to work, except he didn't.
The artist was going through a rough patch.
It's dipping back into depression and public experienced and artistic block and
spent weeks staring at the empty canvas. He missed the November deadline,
but surely afterward he had a vision,
a stampede of every animal in the American West cows and horses and antelopes
and buffaloes.
Everything is charging across that surface driven by this rapture painted
his mural in a single burst of energy around new year's day of 1944.
The stampede had morphed into a kinetic tsunami of abstract shapes.
Mural was recognized as a turning point for American art and it helped put
Jackson on the artistic map of New York.
He could count on the Guggenheim patronage, of course, but most importantly,
he was champions by influential art, grey sick Kevin's greenback.
I took one look at it and I thought, now that's great art.
And I knew Jackson was the painter. This country had produced
Was 45 Jackson and Lee tied the knots.
And in November they moved into the new house,
say 230 Springs fireplace road in Springs, long Island,
New York Jackson converted a nearby barn into a large studio,
large enough to lay enormous canvases on the floor.
Three from the constraints of the traditional easel,
the painter was able to perfect the technique for which he became famous.
The technique has become known as drip painting or action painting or gestural
painting by defining the convention of painting on an upright surface.
Paul encountered a new dimension to his creative process.
He was now able to view and applying paints to his canvases from all directions
and not just any artists, paint, preferred household paints,
varnishes and enamels to drip and fling. These materials,
public used hardens brushes sticks,
and even basting syringes in the process of perfecting the star public moved
away from figurative representation,
even avoiding vague shadows of recognizable shapes.
His work Lucifer of 1947 is a good example of this transition.
Public had started this painting by applying color to the canvas in a
traditional way. But halfway through the process, he went into full action mode.
He dripped spattered pigments on an underlayer into which he had embedded small
pieces of gravel to increase the text jet while completing Lucifer Polich
devised another original technique.
Every time he had to dip his brush into varnish,
the interruption to his free hand movements restricted him.
He then tried to tilt a can of household panes,
allowing it to run down a stick at the right angle.
Lucifer runs other similar works to the period,
debuted at the Betty Parsons gallery in New York in 1948.
You would think that with Greenberg behind him,
the exhibition would be a success best. No, it was a critical disaster.
The wider general public in the U S are simply not yet ready for Pallex action
paintings. Europe was a different story there.
Peggy Guggenheim constantly moving between New York and Venice took the occasion
to show six of Pollock's works at the prestigious Venice monopoly.
The paintings were greatly appreciated by Italian and European critics.
And so the talk continued into Milan and Florence.
It's worth mentioning that just a couple of years earlier,
the us state department had sponsored a touring exhibition of other American
abstract expressionists,
the same school to which public belonged the exhibition was called advancing
American art.
It had the explicit intention of showcasing American abstract artists in Europe
and beyond the iron curtain. The message was clear.
The U S was the home of the free open to all forms of artistic expression,
as opposed to the drab stage controlled realist arts coming from communist bloc
countries. Now keep that in mind shortly after Pollock's European exhibitions,
Jackson made it to the mainstream on August the eighth,
1949 readers of life magazine got to know the painter.
He appeared as a brooding puzzled looking man on a two-page spread,
standing in front of one of his large murals.
The title of the article reds is either the greatest living painter in the
United States,
49 and the early 1950s was on a roll.
This is when he produced number one and autumn rhythm.
Arguably the two examples in which abstract expressionism and action painting
are at their highest pallet. These large canvases lack,
a central point of focus. There is no hierarchy,
no dominance of one elements over the other.
Every bit of the surface is equally important.
Pollexfen own Europeans or at no further motive than to advance his own art.
And apparently it worked.
His paintings had to establish credibility in Europe before being appreciated at
home. Despite the wave of success and appreciation critics was still divided.
If life had politics back telling magazine dismissed his art as chaos,
hence his famous reply via telegram, no chaos,
Pollack firmly stated that he had a clear idea of how he wanted a particular
piece to appear more precisely.
FM's complete control over the movements of his implements, his hands,
his body random forces did come into play.
When the paint fell over the canvas and accepted that the viscosity of the
material, the absorption factor of the canvas, even the force of gravity,
those were the uncontrollable elements, wrestling with the controllable ones,
creating a synthesis new meaning perhaps in public's mind.
It was similar to how the human psyche and human behavior are a result of
conscious and unconscious factors. Finally, Polak regains control.
As the abstract images took shape on the canvas.
It was he who decided what colors or lines to add,
and he would not stop until he saw what he wanted to see. Contemporary myths,
depict Jackson, as a Bewitched artist,
high on alcohol who randomly flung pains while ecstatically dancing to the
improvisational jazz of masters, like Charlie Parker, his wife,
Lee Krasner later denied this.
Not only did his studio lack the electricity needed to plug in a record player,
but didn't really dig those cans, blurting out bebop and cool jazz.
He preferred old-fashioned big band classics. If the Dixieland era,
this myth was further dispels by the analysis of art critic.
Robert Good Norton's have a Carmel.
They just don't do a documentary of Polica at work shot by filmmaker.
Hans namer fins were able to describe Jackson's working method in four phases.
Phase one,
start your masterpiece by tracing some loosely representational figures,
phase two, immediately over paint and obscure. These figures.
These two phases should take it up two hours and leave you awesomely exhausted.
Phase three, take a can of black or dark enamel dip,
a stubby brush and move your arm rhythmic knee.
The pains will drip fall and splash in a variety of movements onto the surface.
Within half an hour,
the entire surface will be covered in weaving rhythms and patterns. Phase four,
over the following two weeks,
you will get accustomed to the painting resounding to it,
to apply additional layers of color in a slower and more deliberate fashion.
Good noughts and CommonWell gave a good description of the process.
When it came to interpreting the results.
We just have to quote the much later studies published on nature by Richard
Taylor, Adam McCullough, and David Jonas.
The researchers analyzed autumn rhythm among other works and realized that
Pollock's paintings presented fractal patterns,
practicals that never ending infinitely complex patterns that are self-similar.
Whether you view them from up close from very far away,
the trio of authors found assumption,
geometric regularity in the apparently irregular surfaces of Pollock's
masterpieces. But what was the meaning behind this?
The three main interpretations,
all the public ones had to replicate fractals observed in nature,
such as trees or coastlines,
or that he wanted to represent a mathematical model of a fractal.
The fracture is observed on the canvas where simply an unintentional
representation of Pollock's movements. In other words,
the painting was merely an object to trace left behind by the events of the
artist, working in a studio. And that the events is what counted
Regardless of interpretations descriptions and explanations.
Jackson was huge by the 1950s,
he was seen as the leader of the new Vanguard of abstract expressionists,
Peggy Guggenheim and Greenberg had played that part. Sure,
but Polycon his mates.
Good counts on one more powerful ally that us government and the CIA remember
the exhibits and tour organized by the state department in 1947. Well,
it's a backfire. It emerged that many abstract expressionists,
including Polak were socialists or communists.
This prompted the political establishment to condemn their art.
Senator George Lindero declared all modern art is communistic Harold
hobby or Los Angeles.
Councilman gave us this Pell modern art is actually a means of espionage.
If you know how to read them, modern paintings will disclose weak spots in us,
fortifications and such crucial constructions.
As the Boulder dam paintings are secret missives to the USSR about American weak
points. Well, there's probably a movie there somewhere,
or at least a good conspiracy theory circles within the state department.
And CIA though,
still felt that sponsoring American modern art would be a good plan.
The end game was to display Soviet realist art from getting any traction in
Europe, but they could not do it openly. Conveniently.
The presidents of the museum of modern art and New York was Nelson Rockefeller,
whose connections with the CIA and the diplomatic service with deep rooted.
So in 1952, the CIA gave MoMA a five-year grants,
father Rockefeller brothers funds. In order to funds the international program,
the museum was able to organize 33 international exhibitions of abstract
expressionists art across four years with CIA money,
European galleries were flooded with works by, Mark Rothko, Willem de Kooning,
and similar artists in the same year.
produced convergence collage of colors that created most of all shapes and
lines, evoking, violent emotions, real assault on the eye,
surely not very accessible. And yet it became his best known work.
Thanks to the promotion grants ed by the international program.
And to the fact that his nature,
it was turned into a best-selling jigsaw puzzle that has often happens with
successful, but troubled artists,
the pressures of notoriety contributed to Pollock's personal deterioration.
His bouts of depression, worsened,
his alcoholism deepened his behavior became more erratic and anecdote of the
time tells us how he wants walked into an after show, party, stock,
and acres and urinated into a fireplace in 1955 painted scent and such,
which would be his last to officially recognize paintings.
According to a friend Jeffrey Potter,
the following year became an abyss of non productivity spends by Jackson in a
death trance on a personal level.
His marriage with Lee had deteriorated as well.
Mocking twin calamities during a night's Ben's drinking at his favorite bar,
the Cedar Jackson Massey 26 year old model and gallerist the beautiful reef
Clayman. According to Ruth, the meeting had been coincidental.
According to artist, Audrey flack,
she had precise plans to seduce the top artist of the New York scene.
In any case, the two began a target effect.
Their relationship was only physical at first, but soon after they fell in love.
Lee was understandably distraught and decided to move out of their home in
Springs, boarding a cruise ship to Europe,
Ruth moved in the very same day during the early months of that love affair.
Kingdon was frustrated by Pollock's lack of interest in art.
Then one day in July,
she insisted he painted a new piece for her public relented and set to work.
The result, according to Ruth was the piece red, black, and silver.
Although the attribution is disputed by most art critics, add Jackson,
found new inspiration, the new muse and reef.
What do you have crawled out of his trance ready to revolutionize the art?
Well to get again? Well, one of a note on August the 11th,
1956 at 10:15 PM, Jackson, Ruth, and their friends,
Edith Metzger with driving in politics,
Oldsmobile convertible Jackson was at the wheel driving under the influence of
alcohol, less than a mile away from his Springs home,
the Oldsmobile veered off the road and crashed. Ruth was the only survivor.
The relationship between Lee and Jackson at the end may have been stormy for
sure, but after Pollock's death, Krasner kept his memory and legacy alive.
She ensured that his short-lived fame did not beat her out snuffed by the new
American trends, such as pop art and realism,
definitely more figurative and style politics. Art was divided in its Genesis.
It came from a struggle between conscious and unconscious.
It derived from controllable and uncontrollable elements.
It was driven by anti conformism, but backed by the establishment.
And so his legacy was, and still is divisive.
You may love him or you may despise him, but surely you can't ignore him.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe and thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].